hey guys Merry Christmas Happy Christmas
whatever they say it's about 9 p.m. on
Christmas Eve and Martin shkreli is live
streaming his life on YouTube you might
remember skellies brush with Fame back
in September 2015 after the young CEO
he's 32 acquired the license to
manufacture a drug that is vital to HIV
patients he raised the price over five
thousand percent we needed to turn a
profit on the drug
shkreli ended up with the kind of
negative attention after evils come back
take value piece of [ __ ] that would make
most people try to disappear most people
instead he started broadcasting his life
on the internet sometimes up to 12 hours
a day
he'd play chess or guitar message girls
on OKCupid and answer questions that
viewers would chat or even call in my
fan of gucci mane of course I'm a fan of
theirs ok Brick Squad soldier he'd even
feed the trolls enjoy the Senate
investigation you fought ok I will
sounds like that will make you mad in
the early days of his livestream shkreli
would offer investing tips and even
trade stocks can't believe I'm shorting
a stock on like live TV then in December
the FBI arrested him with charges of
securities fraud and accused him of
running a Ponzi like scheme shkreli is
now out on bail and even though he's
careful about discussing investing or
his case he's still broadcasting his
life the number of viewers watching live
at any given moment could be 25 for
hundreds depending on the time of day
and what he's doing
I'll be right back people I'm gonna mute
often viewers hang out and chat with
each other even when shkreli isn't there
a community of curious and
charmed shkreli fans has formed hey LA
okay Billy the mark morning Hawks ilysm
how are you hey mochi cool card trick
sauce nineties but why does shkreli live
stream at all especially now that he's
being indicted by the SEC I tried to ask
shkreli about this directly in the live
stream it took a lot of attempts before
he responded no but I can tell you these
shots
well that wasn't super helpful
yes no so I asked the community what
they thought Shirley was getting out of
this Internet experiments
most of them asked to remain anonymous
sometimes citing fear of backlash from
the community or even shkreli himself
but their ideas were pretty predictable
some think he's just doing it for the
attention and he does receive a lot of
attention you are so attractive and
funny you don't deserve all I hate well
thank you that's uh that's exactly how I
feel I love you Martin I love you too
you look like my next husband that's
nice others think shkreli is dreaming to
fight the negative image of himself to
prove to the world that he's actually a
good guy over time I would like people
to better understand me but that I can't
ask ask for that to occur overnight you
know people just gotta watch evil that's
true I feel eeeh but really well he may
not have a reason at all and he doesn't
need one this virtual community has
popped up partly because shkreli defies
reason if you could rewind the clock a
few months I wonder if you would do
anything differently I probably would
have raised the price higher this is
probably what I would have done
so this almost makes perfect sense in a
way ironically many members of Skelly's
livestream community told me they
actually prefer the live stream when
shkreli isn't there because then they
don't have to deal with trolls and could
just hang out so regardless of scrubbies
fates the community that he's fostered
will likely live on even if shkreli is
behind bars far away from a webcam and
computer chess